Let's take a closer look at shoulder
seams when working cut and sew.
In this sample, I've knit
a back and two cardigan fronts.
I scrapped off the shoulders.
Each has 20 stitches, and I scrapped
off the neck openings separately.
Now, for this sample,
I then used a template to mark the neck
openings, but this is a case
of "do as I say, not as I did."
What I should have done was join the
shoulders, then marked the neck opening.
Either way, you can see my shoulder
join with the waste yarn removed.
The marks and the upcoming stitch lines
are carefully positioned away
from that shoulder seam.
I left my orange neck
opening waste yarn in place.
You could also choose to bind off the neck
openings, but this whole area is going
to be cut away and the raw edges
will be enclosed with my band.
Here is the single line
of straight stitches.
Notice that I did not sew
those shoulder seam stitches.
Then a line or two of zig -zag should
be enough to secure my stitches.
Notice that I didn't stitch
along those shoulder stitches.
When using a serger,
you have to be extra careful not
to stitch those shoulder stitches.
The secret here is to isolate those
shoulder stitches when stitching
and cutting the neckline.
Now, it's difficult to see in this photo,
but when hanging the neck edge
on the machine to form the band,
care needs to be taken to secure
those shoulder stitches.
Even though we stretch the neckline when
hanging it on the machine for
a neat finish, don't stretch
in that shoulder seam area.
Once you finish the band,
the neck edge should be neat and tidy
along those secure shoulder seams.